right okay so hello everyone uh thank
you for coming here so uh numerous lee i
guess
uh so yeah as a he said i'm tobias
i
have been working for embw for like 1.5
years roughly
and worked there on predictive modeling
and anomaly detection and basically
something that's called condition
monitoring i'm going to try to explain
to you in this talk what kind of
problems we face and how we're
planning on solving and how we're
solving them currently
and all the challenges that are ahead
and so forth so this is a table of
contents first a little bit
at first i will talk about condition
monitoring at embw so i will talk about
an application called embw asset radar
which is like a proprietary
software that embw
develops in-house we'll talk about data
sources so what kind of data do we have
available about our wind turbines to
monitor them
go and talk about anomaly detection
first like in a more general sense i
will define what that actually is and
you know maybe you'll see that it's
actually kind of difficult or more
difficult than you would assume i'm
going to talk about predictive modeling
then what's the idea behind that how do
you do that what you know what kind of
challenges are there and then i'm going
to talk about that topic specifically
and
how we use that at embw how we do it and
then about future plans a concept
we coined as anomaly space and how we
use that and then a hopefully very
helpful example to understand what we're
doing and why we're doing exactly that
all right so let's get started so first
of all i want to talk about
asset radar so asset rater is a as i
said like a proprietary application
and um it's
the way it works currently is it
monitors roughly 450 wind turbines that
are located in germany or some other
parts of europe mostly sweden i think
and the idea there is that it monitors
all relevant components
that means not every single one of them
but only those that are judged to be
important for maintenance
uh we use multiple detection methods so
it's not really that just like one thing
we do but we actually have like a
set of
either established or
a customized methods we use to uh
keep track of our uh units and all that
is as i said already and bundled in
proper proprietary software
and uh it basically
collects data like in this little
graphic on the bottom there
you see the parks collect data send that
to a park server and the park server
then sends that to the cloud and
everything that's in that little
bluish i suppose cloud that is pretty
much what asset radar does and acid
raider then sends alert to
diagnosticians and those are actually
humans right so these are
real engineers that know
wind turbine energy and actually look at
the data and confirm whether what is
spotted by asset rater is in fact
a
a real concern or not at all and then it
they will decide then how to proceed
with that like usually uh they would
indicate stuff like on-site uh
follow-ups or stuff like that
all right the objectives
overall
of asset rater are to
minimize
on-site maintenance that's really
important so we want to go there as
little as possible and as early as
possible because the rule of thumb is
the earlier you repair something the
cheaper it is
so and you really want to have those
cheap ones because basically if you wait
too long
the worst case is you have to basically
replace the whole thing and you don't
want to do that except for the tower
that's usually not something that breaks
very easily
yeah and we want to monitor all units
operated by ebw that includes actually
solar
power plants and water power plants and
so forth
we want to use all data that is
available to us so we don't want to skip
on anything or
miss any any defects and
the main goal is continuous development
and improvement so we don't want to
be stuck on like one state and just ship
that forever but we want to keep going
and use the knowledge we gather from the
diagnosticians and
put that into the application right so
that is about that now i'm going to talk
about
data sources and one and the most
important data sources i'm going to talk
about here that's called scada it's
short for supervisory control and data
acquisition something i only learned
when i talk about it in talks but yeah
we usually call it scada
and what scada is it continuously
collects data from multiple sensors like
you know temperatures pressures currents
all kinds of physical quantities
and then aggregates that in 10-minute
intervals so we don't really look at the
raw data which could have any sampling
rate i don't even know actually what the
raw sampling rate is because we only
look at scada data
and these ten minute intervals they are
summarized in like you know the mean the
min the max
and the standard deviation and that's
pretty much all we work with
um and that's an example i guess of what
it looks like so those are just two
really random
uh signals uh the top is like a bearing
temperature and the top and the bottom
is like a wind speed that is uh measured
by something we call anemometer
which is like an instrument to measure
wind speed so as and the shaded area is
like everything between min and max and
the straight line is then the mean
usually we have a standard deviation too
i didn't put this in here so you can see
anything at all so
yeah so that's the data we're working
with on the scada side then we have
oscillation data that's a tad more
complicated so that's basically
acceleration data collected
uh in in strategic locations in the
machine
really the way you can think about this
is imagine like tiny little microphones
that measure what kind of noise the
machine is making and those are not
continuously measuring because you need
very high sampling rates for this like
you're like up to 50 kilohertz or
something like that you can't really
afford that on these tiny computers
there on the machine so you do that
regularly you just kind of like
trigger a measurement when it's
useful and then you have a few seconds
of like an audio clip of what the unit
sounds like it's kind of like when you
sit in the car and something's wrong
with the car and you can kind of hear
like where it comes from that's
basically what this is
and that allows for a very specific
analysis of the faults because basically
the way it works is you have the
drivetrain so the drivetrain i have to
explain maybe is everything that rotates
in the wind turbine that's part of the
drivetrain so the rotor blades in the in
the front and then the generator in the
back and then the gear in the middle and
you have a lot of translations of these
rotations into different frequencies so
whenever you see maybe i could just go
to the next one
and whenever you see like a frequency
that peaks
you know which part of the turbine is
creating that peak so when you see a
growing peak over time you usually know
like okay something in the turbine that
is rotating with that frequency is
having some trouble there right so here
maybe for some more explanation top is
the raw data so really like an audio
clip you could actually listen to that
you can actually listen to that in acid
raider i think
and the bottom is just a spectrum like
an fft if that says anything to you
so really straightforward processing
there to analyze the frequencies
all right so now i'm going to talk about
anomaly detection and why it's such a
hard problem
so
i try to like explain this with as
little formulae as possible let's see
how i fare
so basically
when you would ask yourself like what
would i consider an anomaly would
probably say something like oh yeah well
an anomaly is something that's not
normal and uh you will probably catch
yourself
uh using that word in the vagus of terms
because it's actually very hard to
define what is normal
and usually all kinds of things go into
a definition of normal like it's not
just
you know something very objective but
it's actually something like the
business case
is interwoven into your definition of
normal and in the case of a wind turbine
what do you want the wind turbine to do
right you want it to produce electricity
and you better hope that is as much
electricity as can be produced right so
that is your
concept of normal but it's still it's
not that simple really because it's a
very technical
term and a lot of complexity is involved
in there so
that's why i said it's very much
non-trivial
statistically maybe you would define
something like
a density or something like that so here
on the right you see like i call this
some feature it's just some toy example
of data and you can plot a histogram of
that or something like that and then you
can maybe fit like a pdf to that model
that's the orange line right and you
would say
an anomaly is an observation you made in
a region where that
orange line is very small basically so
everything above 1.5 or below minus 1.5
you would maybe consider an anomaly in
this case or an outlier depending of on
how you phrase that
right so in this univariate case this
seems to be
very easy even though calculating a
density
from data alone is notoriously difficult
as some of you might know
so and it gets more complicated when you
look at multivariate data right like so
here i extended the data from before by
another dimension
and you can see
here this orange star in the middle
uh you would maybe consider completely
normal in the univariate marginal
distributions or these projections
really
but
in the
joint view of both features at the same
time this is actually like kind of
obviously a really odd one
there in the middle of this strange
curve there so and of course this
problem gets harder and harder the
higher the dimensionality of your data
and another problem that was actually
kind of obvious with the univariate case
too is
uh the decision has to be made like when
is p so small
that you will actually uh frame this as
an
anomaly right like that is actually kind
of a very subjective
decision and it's kind of tied to the
question like how often do we expect
anomalies to occur
and also a follow-up problem of this is
if you can never really objectively
decide whether something is an anomaly
or not how do you find like a you know a
data set that is actually completely
normal that you can train any algorithms
on right
and um the time series we have time
series in in this case and time series
are actually especially difficult
because really every data point kind of
depends on all previous data points and
you can actually easily find
samples that look completely fine and
when you look at them in an isolated way
but the way it evolved over time is
completely off
right so
one way out of this or like one
treatment of this i suppose is
predictive modeling and i'm going to
present to you like the idea behind it
in the context of wind turbines
so really the expectation is that if you
have a healthy system
then
pretty much there should be very stable
and robust relationship between
certain signals or certain data that is
provided by that system right in the
case here of the wind turbine that you
see here on the right
uh what does the wind turbine see it
mostly sees like wind speed and
direction it sees like air temperature
and air pressure and so forth and it
really just reacts to these
environmental features it there's it
kind of works autonomously for the most
part
and then you should actually be able to
predict all other signals from this
right this would be like the wishful
thinking or whatever
and uh so what there's really no reason
why you couldn't replace that wind
turbine by a statistical model so why
don't we just do that try to predict
every other signal and if we get
significantly worse than usual or than
in the training set then we know
something's off right and those
deviations from uh the usual predictive
performance we could basically just
label uh a defect right that would be
basically the idea so the way we use
this at embw is
fairly simple so
this is an example for like three input
signals and one target signal in gray
the shaded area is the training period
and the training period is mostly
determined by those diagnosticians i
mentioned earlier they would look at the
data they will see like okay this
first year of abrasion by by for example
looks fairly innocuous let's use it
and maybe we'll cut out like a few weird
looking bits of it or whatever and then
we'll have our training period it's very
important that a training period by the
way is one full year of data because it
turns out that seasons are a thing
and you kind of want to account for that
so this training period then we split up
in a train and test set
like this maybe we usually use a one to
six ratio which uh makes no difference
but that's what we do
and on the train set then with the train
set we train a regression model we
for the most part use uh just
gbrts and try and regression model on
that and then evaluate that on the test
set and
from the test set we then get like a set
of model deviations that the model has
never seen right on on samples that the
model has never seen and that uh test
set of model deviations we can really
use to gauge
our
our system and to
answer the question like how
when is a model deviation unusual enough
to
give an alert or whatever
right so this is basically then the
result we have model deviations on the
test set
those can you know theoretically have
any shape that can be skewed or long
tails or whatever
and then we want to decide like what is
unusual the way we do this right now is
we just do a make a statistical modeling
of this of some kind
that's the orange curve here and then we
basically set like a lower threshold for
this and an upper threshold for this
that can't be crossed
based on really pretty much like a
quantile that is indicated by the
statistical model
all right so that's what we do with
that
okay then uh one
well a problem really to to to solve is
uh
this trade-off here between specific
and uh generic so what this really means
is we could theoretically
choose a model that is super generic we
just dump everything into the model and
try to estimate from that dump of inputs
everything that comes out we could for
example think of an auto encoder of some
some some type right that would give you
the advantage of very few models in this
case maybe even just one
and you have very complete monitoring
because you can just dump everything in
and you're done basically but the
problem here is um it's extremely hard
to interpret these models for the most
part because of uh you know you you may
think something like well every um
every signal that i didn't reconstruct
probably is the signal i want to look at
but usually you have like issues with
like cause and effect in these models
and it's not that easy actually to do so
also another downside is we actually
have engineers on board at enbw they
know their machines very well and we
didn't not did not use that knowledge at
all right so we basically look at
everything not at the things that the
engineers are interested in
so and then the trade-off on the other
end is specific models with few inputs
so that of course gives you then a lot
of models in our case it is a lot of
models like 20 000 or something like
that
so that's of course a
sort of a maintenance problem as well
and of course not every signal that the
machine records is necessarily monitored
right like so it's only the things are
monitored that the engineers decide to
look at and the hope is of course that
the engineers know their machines well
enough to know that we won't miss
anything
on the upside though each model
indicates like a very
small subset of diagnoses so we don't
just uh you know know something's off
vaguely like in the case of the
autoencoder but we actually kind of know
like which relationship is violated in
that in the machine and we can actually
make very specific
follow-ups and look at these things
in this very specific way
which is of course not perfect you still
have like you know a number of input
signals and you never know like okay
who's the culprit here you always have
to check and you always have to check
maybe with other models too and so forth
so there's still like some manual um
work to do but at least not as much as
with the auto encoder and of course yeah
well the engineering knowledge is now
there i think that's kind of obvious
all right so then on this kind of empty
slide you see
our future plan of automatic diagnosis
so really the problem we have we're
facing right now is we have a lot of
units right now we have very few
diagnosticians
and in the future we assume that there
will probably probably be more units to
come right like way more we all hope i
suppose um
and so we kind of need to have like some
some sense of scalability we want to
know like how much can we scale this
without
basically linearly scaling the number of
diagnosticians at work
so what we really need there is we need
the models to give us or we need a model
really to give us more precise pointers
on what to look at
to facilitate
the process of getting to a diagnosis
and the idea here is basically what we
want to develop is some type of
meta model that learns from previous
defects puts things together and kind of
like uh you know mix and match uh
certain
uh previous uh defects with new ones
so but there's of course like a huge
number of challenges with this involved
like so this cluster of words here is
supposed to give you like a sense of
just how diverse the data really is
we're working with so it's not like we
all have like one type of wind turbine
that we put everywhere and then that's
the end of it and they don't
they they're not all equipped with the
same kind of sensors and they don't have
all the same uh type of specifications
in fact like even stuff like components
here right like there are wind turbines
that don't even have gears so
a gear failure on a gearless wind
turbine is probably not a very likely
diagnosis i suppose
so and like that we have all kinds of
other things like let me mention like
weather and seasons that's also a really
complicated one if we for example see a
defect and it was used to be like kind
of stormy or there were like a few wind
gusts there
kind of unusual maybe for the season or
something like that then whatever meta
model you train on that that probably
will point out that every gusty season
is a defect and you don't want that so
that's kind of difficult to account for
too like you know in the best case we
actually would displace
defect wind turbines with all kinds of
defects
all over germany and just let it run for
a year and then we had enough data but
that's not possible or
at least it's not very economical so we
kind of have to find a way to kind of
ignore everything that's relevant so
that's a very tough problem to solve
the next challenge is labels so
well we have diagnosticians and they do
their job of course but we still have
kind of incomplete labels because
not the whole lifetime of every unit we
have
is fully monitored in the same way
so we're missing some um we're missing
some labels here and there and so forth
and um
also defects are really rare right like
uh
as a data scientist i can say it's
unfortunate as everyone else like normal
people they would probably say that's
actually really good right but uh so
we're missing labels uh i pointed out a
few like rough
units here uh 450 units we have
uh seven years of average lifetime and
roughly 80 monitored signals per unit on
average actually it's more but 80 is
just the number of signals we monitor so
that would combine into like
252 000 years of data with a 10 minute
resolution that's like a few billion
samples really
and that's of course a lot and you would
think like oh yeah it's a lot so just
train a huge neural network on it or
something but that's actually not really
possible because of the heterogeneity
problem
right so and of that data
it's uh only 0.05 percent which is
actually in any way labeled to have a
defect or some
kind of
i don't know unusual behavior so that's
very very little because you can barely
see that red little bar there right
so that's another huge problem we just
don't have the labels really to train
anything more sophisticated
and that's also kind of a problem
so our solutions to this problem or our
solution to the problem right now is uh
the anomaly space
it's something we coined i don't know
where it exactly comes from but the idea
is basically
we don't actually look at
our
units in the sense of their absolute
measurements like oh the bearing
temperature was 50 degrees or something
like that like nothing absolutely
specific like this but rather we just
look at every component of our unit in
the context
of the unit like the question isn't like
what is the bearing temperature but the
question is
uh how unusual is that bearing
temperatures given the current
conditions and we basically collect all
kinds of anomaly detectors like that
that always give us like a normalized
view of how unusual something is
and we work with that right and the
reason why we need to do this again like
i talked about heterogeneity but there's
also the problem of like
slight differences in in how the sensors
are installed even in units of the same
type so it's kind of difficult to work
with that
and from that we hope to
extract a signature
of every defect and
from that we hope that we can actually
recognize defects from earlier
and
then the question is of course like why
do we need so many detectors like
because you can see here like this on
the right here is like a collection of
heat maps for every single detector we
have available for like i think one unit
and that's just like a little crop of
the actual full
list so why do we need so many and i
have an example here that's hopefully
kind of helpful to understand like also
what the diagnosticians are really doing
so
here is an example of a power output
model so what that does is it takes like
the wind speed and the temperature and
like the position
of the wind turbine relative to the wind
and so forth and tries to estimate from
that what is the expected power output
of that unit right it's very fairly
simple i think
and we see here in this region it has
actually very unusual deviations from
the norm right like before that before
the shaded area it looks way different
from what it looks like inside so you
think like oh something's wrong with the
power output of the unit uh sounds
really complicated
and then you look maybe you check first
okay how does this power output actually
compare
with the neighboring units right because
they all see that like roughly the same
wind so you'd expect like on average
they would kind of cancel out to like
have no difference at all and as you can
see here that's actually the case here
so there's actually nothing wrong with
the power output of that unit because it
has the same power output as the rest of
it so that's kind of disheartening and
then you would probably go on and look
at this here which is
a model we created so think about uh the
wind turbine as a giant wind speedometer
or anemometer we call that usually so it
just measures the wind speed in a very
robust way
and then additionally to that we usually
have two mechanical enemometers this is
such a difficult word to say by the way
uh we have two anemometers installed on
the unit that redundantly measure the
wind speed so we have three uh things
that measure the same thing so we can
kind of like tell whether one is odd and
in this case and it's kind of like shown
in the bottom of the two plots
sensor one two of the two sensors is
actually defective and so you know what
at first maybe look like uh you know
problem with like a complex problem with
the operation of the unit actually turns
out just to be a defective anemometer
because uh you know some bird takes
revenge or something like that
you laugh but that's actually something
that happens so
um
all right so uh and that i think
concludes my talk already so here's some
summary you can read it i guess and uh
let's move on to the q a i suppose so
thank you very much for listening
so your last chance to vote
if you haven't done it already
um
the first question maybe i'll come over
here
the first question i have from the
audience is how do you handle
time-windowed features if you cut out
certain periods in your training data
um well it really depends on what we're
doing really
like sometimes it's sufficient like
depending on what we do again uh
sometimes sufficient to just set them to
zero fill them with some nuns sometimes
with some zeros i'm sorry and sometimes
we can interpolate interpolate these or
whatever but uh usually um yeah it's so
dependent on like what we do exactly so
it's really difficult to answer that in
a generic way yeah that's my answer
okay so there's room for further
discussion after the talk i i guess so
yeah
um
okay this one seems to be fairly high
upvoted how do you evaluate your model
detection performance do you have a set
of anomalous data yeah that is a very
difficult question and so far that uh
that is a problem we're still working on
of course we have some label data right
and we have some attempts at like
evaluating our models and that but it's
it's a very interesting question to ask
because
you would for example think like okay we
have a
predictive modeling and
we can now estimate the performance of
the regressor for example and maybe that
is a good uh indicator of how good the
model is but that usually turns out not
to be the case like those are really
independent things the capacity
to detect
defects and the capacity to just predict
whatever is happening
on another input signal so yeah we have
some
ways to benchmark
our models just by checking them against
defects in case we have some which is
not always the case of course
but that's pretty much the end of it
like it's also not the case that we like
do some extensive hyper parameter tuning
or whatever that's usually not something
uh we attempt because it seems like a
waste of time really
okay thank you very much
um
don't you need to train on two years of
data to learn about seasonality somebody
asks
well i would then ask like why though
but
yeah i mean like very often we actually
do extend our training period longer
than one year that's actually kind of
common in case we feel like there's not
enough data
to back up certain
weather
conditions and so forth but yeah i'd be
curious to know like why exactly it
should be exactly two years and not one
year
like uh maybe we can talk about that
after if you can find me somewhere
yeah um can you elaborate on the
infrastructure where and how the models
are run how does the gate data get there
do you use a stream do you streaming api
calls batch predictions
very long question here we have well uh
yeah i'm not an expert in that i have to
say like i'm mostly just a data
scientist and use the stuff that the
data engineers shows over to us but we
work in the azure cloud of course
of course i don't know why i said that
[Laughter]
really i don't know why i said that
anyways
um yeah we we use everything we use i
think azure functions in the measure
cloud and that's pretty much the extent
of my knowledge yeah and we use an
influx db to store
all the signals and query them
yeah let's see if we have question uh
time for one more question
um
how do you deal with anomaly score
spikes versus gradually increasing
anomaly scores do you use the same
threshold or separate ones that's
another really interesting question
because um when we ask diagnosticians um
what are you looking for in in these
model deviations they usually will tell
us we look for trends we don't usually
look for like outliers or whatever like
little spikes but we usually look for
they usually look for trends so very
slow um you know crawling up from from
from around zero or whatever
and we do have basically like we have
some monitors that actually work by
specifically looking for trends instead
of
spikes in case that you know these
spikes are not really
very useful to look at we also try to
ignore you know outliers actually so
which is actually kind of
counter-intuitive because most people
would think outliers and anomalies are
kind of the same but we really look for
robust trends we look for like actually
like paradigm shifts in the way the unit
operates not really for like you know
statistical fluctuations in any sense
then i would like to thank you for a
very very interesting talk maybe we can
have a